[Music]
look around you attentively what you see
is not what is there your sensorial
apparatus is being targeted by lots of
different signals from the environment
and everything is conspiring to creating
a definite sharp image of this room the
light the color position of chairs
number of people they all have a
definite value all of these properties
and yet we know from physics that this
is not what is really there all the
particles in this room those that
compose your bodies the photons in the
light and there is other things things
that make sound propagate phonons etc
are all quantum mechanical particles and
that means that most of their properties
are not sharp are not definite quantum
mechanical particles exist in states
where if you wanted to measure some of
the properties of these particles most
of the times you would get an answer of
which you can only predict the
probability but is uncertain is
indefinite and for this property I will
use the word on sharpness
this is unsharp Nisour quantum systems
and this is what actually gives the
appearance at the macro scale of these
definite features that we all can see so
let's take a look
classically what we know is that objects
have definite properties so for example
if you want to describe a neutron
you can for instance say that a neutron
is at a particular position zero or it's
in a different position one these two
positions are distinguishable you can
also assign an energy to the neutron and
lots of other properties spin etc and
they're all definite quantum
mechanically picture is completely
different there is a state where the
neutron is in position zero does it say
it where the neutron is in position one
but also there is this particular state
here which I represent pictorially like
that where we can only predict the
probability for the neutron to be in
position 0 or 1 but the position is
unsharp and these states are called
super positions and notice that these
unsharp ness has nothing to do whereas
very little to do with stochastic
uncertainty like when you throw a dice
this is a different type of and
sharpness is richer and this is why it's
the key property that powers all of
quantum mechanics features including
those that are used for quantum
computers for quantum cryptography and
for pop for properties like entanglement
there are extreme exotic and different
for what we perceive now this on
sharpness is mind-boggling it's a very
beautiful feature of these quantum
systems but it's also a source of very
interesting problems and one of the most
interesting problems comes up when we
try to ascribe the Sun sharpness to
objects which are demanded by other
physical theories to be sharp all the
time and this is the case of gravity now
general relativity is this theory that
Einstein came up with to describe masses
and the way they interact through
gravitational forces and relativity
theory of gravities in general have no
on sharpness they want their objects to
be all the
I'm sharp in the position there are
energy all of their features so when you
want to describe for instance the
interaction between two masses like this
you can only describe this if you can
assume that these masses are fixed and
have definite positions and then they
interact with respect to one another
through gravitational interactions
general activity can take the unsharp
ness of quantum theory so for example
what happens if instead of two sharp
masses in sharp positions you have
masses that are in quantum
superpositions of different locations so
quantum theory requires every object to
be capable of being these super
positions so we have to consider these
states if we believe in quantum theory
but at the same time if we believe that
these are masses and that they can
gravitate they should also bei general
relativity but general activity doesn't
allow this type of states it can't deal
with this so there's a big question mark
there and physicists are scratching
their heads about this what is going on
how do we describe this now this of
course didn't didn't go unnoticed in the
early days of when pioneers of these two
theories were worth discovering the the
properties of of those two beautiful
descriptions of reality and that led to
a very nice conference that took place
in North Carolina the Chapel Hill
conference and that led to science
friction it was a very very interesting
debate taking place there because there
were two camps one led by Richard
Feynman who was there then a very young
bright scientist trying to understand
what was going on there so that camp was
convinced that
quantum theory is a universal theory so
it should apply to masses and therefore
masses and the gravitational interaction
should obey quantum theory and therefore
they should be capable of being in this
unsharp state so Fineman was campaigning
for having a quantum theory of gravity
but there was another camp there was a
camp of other people who said well it
could be the quantum theory after all is
false at some point that there is a
scale about which he doesn't apply
therefore it could be the gravity is
classical and and these unsharp nurse
leaves gravity untouched and this clash
exists to this day we haven't moved much
forward since then well let me explain
why and this the uncovers a very nice
gap in our current understanding of the
physical world
fascinating up fineman's problem as he
put it was exactly this we have we have
means to create super positions quantum
superpositions of masses possibility of
putting them in this unsharp state in
regard to position
now this mass should do something to the
gravitational field as we say which is
this thing that allows rotational
interactions to occur and if quantum
theory applies gravitational fields
should also respond to this on sharpness
and be kind of dragged into this quantum
state that the mass is already in and
join it into an larger quantum state now
people said yeah this test that sounds
like a good idea let's try to come up
with proposals for what we call quantum
gravity and there are some very
beautiful proposals
that try to describe what's going on in
this case but they're all problematic
and the deepest of their problems is
that whenever they make a prediction
about the features of this joint state
those predictions turn out to be
unaccessible experimentally so the
features of this state can be access to
experiments at the moment our
technologies are not good enough and in
fact there are theories that predict
that gravity should produce the analog
of photons which are called gravitons
quanta of energy of the gravitational
field and turns out that those theory
that say the gravitons exists
they also say that gravitons can't be
detected it takes too long a time for a
graviton to be emitted we wouldn't be
able to see any so how do we test
whether those theories of quantum
gravity are right or not for motivates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the institute of arts and ideas at AI TV
you